the Joe Rogan experience may be the
creak of the cave is a great place for
your comments in New York she's always
like is nothing but greater to make fun
I saw it's it's like they they bring
together young comics and like give them
forming no ones it's it's it is it is
what the Comedy Store was if you take
away the socks a fifth to twelve plus
your class how many seats is it eighty
on top and 1520 in the bottom Jesus I
walked in I walked in it is my
impression of this place at one time
yeah I walked in machines only skank
fest yeah and I walked past re throwing
piss on somebody no nice yeah and I
walked downstairs to a room full of
people with their shirts off good
chanting uh do you remember that re did
you know did you [ __ ] the Tupperware
their [ __ ] in a Tupperware and then
opened it up in the room down the street
I'm starting to get just oh and these
guys were offended by my love [ __ ] into
it see whatever happened happened it was
a pile a bit oh my god question I'm not
sure exactly
sometimes when you [ __ ] it smells awful
and you realize you've [ __ ] so much it's
broken water it's rising like a [ __ ]
toilet bowl you know it's like the Kona
Coast smell like why is it smell so bad
human really really human [ __ ] it's so
bad Mike dogs [ __ ] doesn't smell nearly
as bad
no not even nearly as bad as people like
that yeah it's it smells like hate crime
yeah but Jindo dog [ __ ] once it gets in
between your toes smells worse believe
that dogs aren't drinking that's what it
is they're not drinking whiskey no
eating subway I thought you were gonna
do this thing on dog hydration
water man Easter shouldn't good guys on
a dog has a new product real problem
with dogs you see my water on that [ __ ]
dehydrate your dog nothing human she's
so nasty man you know you what you're
walking like in a city and you see [ __ ]
yeah and then say it so if you just
smell it's good if you smell it it's
like a [ __ ] 90% chance dude that's
why told me in Hong Kong they like
listen if you see hold on not every man
Lander from mainland China shits in
malls but if you see [ __ ] in them all
that's a mainlander yeah they're
disgusting they just [ __ ] in the mall
yeah there's a [ __ ] amazing Chinese
people just [ __ ] in the mall hold on the
bathrooms Oh the ground the ground so
case you walk through the mall you see
human [ __ ] on there oh yeah they don't
know how to be Chinese doors are
underrated
we're stories in the world well I have
Chinese tourists are the wors tourists
when they're saying the Trump we're
gonna hold our tourism back all the
[ __ ] travelers like please keep there
so they just some folks who live in
rural China's alive
the children you've been there yeah but
I have these shorts is wide shorts with
a cut down the middle so when you open
stand-up the cut comes together when you
squat so you don't have to [ __ ] lift
your shorts out it comes out and then
just [ __ ] away [ __ ] where they're
walking ten-year-olds just a shoeless
how do I get those pants for Sunday's
what is this why kids keep crapping in
public and child that's true get burped
with the [ __ ] common sense
that's what if science acid Chinese
tourists not poop on the ground oh my
god roll down that for a second five
worst tourists Chinese far and away
number one like like [ __ ] Richard
Pryor Chinese replace Americans as the
worst tourists in the world we never
words as if they're obnoxious oh my god
this is a terrible article yeah although
although have you ever been a [ __ ] in
public apparently oh my god this is on
Vice yep
UK Vice UK vice how's the air but that
we're so we're reading this folks if you
hear those words I have not said that
I'm reading something off of a other the
title the writers people re did say
everything far the worst tourists Israel
and Russians tied why Israelis I'm
missing Australians the bogans are
garbage are you serious it inflicted
them into the world like go learn on
their turf Wow bogans why I don't have
the army and they think they can [ __ ]
go nuts yeah I don't know but people
don't like Israeli tourists really yeah
they got a reputation about them and you
know that yeah Americans are way down
the line no Americans are not celebrated
in a lot of parts where you travel to
man celebrated a lot of who won who tip
consistently org or people like our
money yep and the ones who travel are
not the [ __ ] rednecks I guess that's
true gone and gone to the world but
sometimes they are that's the church
sometimes there's a lot America saying
there's plenty of obnoxious yeah it's
traveling yeah yeah definitely
but we're not in this top five really
interesting I would have thought it
assumed normally [ __ ] at the mall
horse is insanity dude like for you to
think that people are gonna be like oh
yeah you just got take a [ __ ] what is do
right here it's your life I did worse I
gotta piss in public at other things
that block me make it block me you know
no you know the block now just gonna
[ __ ] real quick it's like we're in the
woods that I gotta piss there's no like
embarrassing level that's how they feel
I don't feel dude they don't even worry
about who cleans it up
- then why Mars no laughing I'm not
everybody do that if every way you
looked at my [ __ ] Jesus
the way you're walking so if you were to
confront somebody like right after you
look the [ __ ] did you just do that
really we talking do you think they
would confront you with like what you
just got in your car yeah what yeah do
you think that it's where they're living
is so overrun with people let they just
[ __ ] anywhere and they don't think that
anybody has a problem with the
environment well now you're asking the
state and I will interpret ation and
yeah I think they have no expectation of
privacy because they're so [ __ ] on
top of each other their homes extremely
clean take off your shoes before you
come inside think about is this thing
like merit I'm not but I'm saying mayn't
but there's an on the mainland you know
China is over a billion people yeah so
you have a lot of like really poor
educated rural parts and like saying
that somebody in that area does this I'd
be like yeah are you saying that like
even somebody that lives in Beijing or
Shanghai who has a job or Wall Street no
they don't no they don't
so that's what say not all mainlanders
will [ __ ] in malls right but if you see
[ __ ] in the mall
it's a bad way and let's be clear when
they say kids what age group is it high
school kids we're trying to [ __ ] or is
it like there's a [ __ ]